einkaufen ohne schlechtes gewissen wer
will das nicht weil die verspricht es
geht klimaneutrale produkte gegen die
erderwärmung viele kunden finden es gut
ist einfach wichtig dass man nicht nur
klimaneutral sich ernährt sondern auch
darauf geachtet regional und ökologisch
im besten fall einzukaufen und ja wenn
es denn so ist das dass diese produkte
auch wirklich diesen tatsachen
entsprechen wenn die skoda ja das finde
ich gut natürlich aber ich weiß nicht so
ganz ehrlich sagen ich weiß nicht so
wirklich was das bedeuten soll
[Applaus]
billig einkaufen und trotzdem das klima
schützen aldi wirbt mit einem
versprechen alle nicht vermeidbaren co2
emissionen die entlang der vorgelagerten
lieferkette entstehen werden durch die
unterstützung von zertifizierten
klimaschutzprojekten vollständig
ausgeglichen so machen wir es zum
beispiel bei unserer klimaneutralen
milch
die heimat der molkerei gropper hier
wird sie produziert die angeblich
klimaneutrale milch und das geht so
eigentlich entstehen 55.000 tonnen co2
von der kuh bis zum discounter regal
ganz schön viel allein seit 2000 20 das
sei aber gar nicht weiter schlimm sagt
aldi denn der co2 ausstoß werde an
anderer stelle ausgeglichen und die
milch so klimaneutral hersteller
suggerieren mit dem begriff klimaneutral
dass ein produkt dem klima nicht schaden
würde das ist so aber falsch und
deswegen irreführend wir wollen wissen
was stimmt denn nun auf seiner homepage
schreibt aldi um die co2 emissionen der
milch auszugleichen werden drei
klimaschutzprojekte unterstützt darunter
zwei regionale in deutschland eines
sticht besonders hervor hilfe für den
wald
[Musik]
diese hilfe soll in thüringen zu finden
sein
simon tanga ding ist förster und
geschäftsführer der schutzgemeinschaft
deutscher wald in bayern bekommt geld
von aldi und anderen unternehmen und
pflanzte mit tannen eichen linden buchen
wo kürzlich noch vertrocknete fichten
standen sollen in einigen jahren gesunde
klima stabile mischwälder stehen doch
das kann dauern
bis dieser wald dem bis heute pflanzen
wieder messwert zum co2 speicher und so
co2 speicher kapazität dort beiträgt
dauert es jetzt erst einmal 20 jahre
eine urkunde bekommt id dafür schon
jetzt
[Musik]
regionale projekte bäume pflanzen
deutschland geht gar nicht sagt der
projektbetreiber
innerhalb von europa ist es nicht
gestattet das offiziell auf europäischen
flächen kompensiert wird also mit
unseren arbeiten können können produkte
nicht klimaneutral gemacht werden das
geht nicht
wir fragen nach bei aldi der konzern
spricht von einem missverständnis die
urkunde wird nach unserer anfrage
korrigiert jetzt heißt das
klimaschutzprojekt co2 ausgleich plus
regionale baumpflanzung eine tonne co2
plus ein baum wobei und deutschland auch
die webseite wird geändert jetzt heißt
es
um die investitionen durch produktion
transport und vertrieb auszugleichen
unterstützen wir international
zertifizierte klimaschutzprojekte
der co2 ausgleich findet also in
wirklichkeit gar nicht in deutschland
statt
sondern international nämlich hier
in den weiten umkreis
wieder geht es um bäume diesmal um ein
aufforstungsprojekt mit australischem
mutter lebt wo einst riesige
rinderherden weideten sollen natürliche
wälder entstehen die tiere und pflanzen
neuen lebensraum geben und nebenbei co2
speichern doch je tiefer wir in den wald
vordringen desto weniger bleibt von der
idylle übrig statt dessen industrielle
forstwirtschaft ein südamerikanischer
holzkonzern feld und zerlegt die bäume
und verschifft sie dann vor allem nach
indien und china
[Musik]
denn purer ist hier der chef
hochwertige holz wird als sperrholz oder
von ihr genutzt
im gegensatz zu holz mit astlöchern dass
man für den rohbau und danach als
bauholz verwenden kann
[Musik]
erste erkenntnis der wald der die all
die milch kompensieren soll ist weniger
ein naturschutzprojekt sondern eher eine
holz plantage
beim eukalyptus handelt es sich nicht um
eine bewaldung sondern um eine
aufforstung sie ist zweifelsfrei ein
geschäft für die zellstoffindustrie zur
papierherstellung und ebenso für die
holz herstellung
in möbeln kann holz co2 langfristig
binden wird zellulose daraus bringt das
für den klimaschutz nichts erklärt uns
ein experte
das problem mit produkten wie zellulose
ist dass sie einen sehr kurzen
lebenszyklus werden manche werden
verbrannt und da hinten auf der
mülldeponie
das ist die schlechteste variante denn
dann entsteht methan das ist noch
schädlich als co2 die emissionen können
am ende anstatt besser sogar schlechter
wäre
aldi beteuert gegenüber frontal die tat
das ziel des aufforstungsprojekt in
uruguay ist die nachhaltige
holzproduktion dabei werden
ausschließlich qualitativ hochwertige
holzstämme produziert und kein zellstoff
mitarbeiter vor ort sagen uns etwas
anderes
diese baumstämme hier landen demnach in
einer zellulosefabrik und auch der chef
widerspricht aldi
in wirklichkeit wenn man über diesen
wald spricht ist eines der ziele die
zellulose herstellung
ein anderer teil der bäume wird als
biomasse für erneuerbare energien
verwendet
das baulos endet normalerweise in der
zellulosefabrik
klimaneutrale all die milch kompensiert
durch fragwürdige industrielle
forstwirtschaft ist das so wirklich
zulässig
internationale standards schreiben vor
das wichtigste kriterium für ein co2
kompensation projekt lautet
zusätzlichkeit im klartext diese
holzplantagen dürfte es nur geben weil
aldi und andere dafür bezahlt haben um
co2 einzusparen doch das scheint nicht
der fall
die holzproduktion ist hier hoch
profitabel das heißt es ist sehr
wahrscheinlich dass das projekt nicht
zusätzlich ist und das co2 geld gar
nicht braucht die zertifikate mögen
zusätzliche einnahmen bringen das
erfüllt aber nicht das kriterium der
zusätzlichkeit
aldi verweist uns an die firma
climatepartner das unternehmen hat
seinen sitz in münchen den weil die sind
auch rewe lidl und edeka co mehr als 500
mitarbeiter erwirtschaften
millionenumsätze ein interview bekommen
wir nicht stattdessen heißt es
schriftlich
die zusätzlichkeit ist ein wesentliches
merkmal von klimaschutzprojekten und bei
den aufforstungsprojekt in grana ii in
uruguay vollumfänglich und nachweislich
gegeben
stimmt dass wir fragen beim chef in
uruguay direkt nach welchen anteil an
ihrem antrag hat die vermarktung von co2
zertifikaten
sie können fragen stellen in der liga
lassen kann ich im moment nicht sagen
und da der verkauf und zertifikate kein
laufendes geschäft ist wie der
holzverkauf
die zertifikate beziehungsweise die co2
reduktion sind für unsere investoren ein
zusatzgeschäft und eine zusätzliche
motivation zu investieren
zusätzlich ist die nicht die
klimarettung sondern der profit es ist
schon schockierend anders zu sehen
schockierend würde es nicht sagen also
alle wollen greenwashing machen
und das also das macht so wie alle
andere ist es nicht überraschend sind
schon das mit und enttäuschung auf jeden
fall ist es immer auch schockierend wenn
man sich nicht darauf verlassen kann
dass zertifikate irgendwie das
halten was sie versprechen
heidi sieht sich dennoch als erster
discounter der klimaneutral handelt
wir haben schon viel erreicht unseren
co2 fußabdruck haben wir seit 2012 um 73
prozent reduziert seit 2017 handeln wir
sogar klimaneutral
damit waren wir der erste lebensmittel
einzelhändler in deutschland
wir sind in ghana westafrika
auch hier hat aldi ein
klimaschutzprojekt das traditionelle
garen über einer offenen feuerstelle
gilt als extrem klimaschädlich in massen
wird wertvoller regenwald abgeholzt und
verbrannt hier setzten aldi und
climatepartner ein zitat
das ziel des koch öfen projekts in
kumasi ist es etwa 25.000 erschwingliche
effiziente und verbesserte koch offen an
haushalte zu verbreiten die zuvor auf
alte ineffiziente offene feuerstellen
angewiesen da an
und so sehen sie aus die koch offen mit
denen aldi nun unmengen co2 einsparen
will die nämlich so heißt es brauchen
nur halb so viel holz kohle wie
traditionelle feuerstellen wir sind bei
der firma management die die öfen für
das aldi projekt produziert vor ort in
sorgsamer handarbeit die öfen sind bei
den kunden beliebt sie werden
subventioniert verkauft und sind
inzwischen weit verbreitet jeder von
ihnen soll 1,5 tonnen co2 pro jahr
sparen
wir stellen mindestens 30.000 pro monat
her es ist nicht leicht zu sagen wie
viel aber es sind schon millionen tonnen
co2 die wir sparen millionen tonnen pro
jahr
wir schauen uns den einsatz der öfen in
der praxis an und besuchen familien mit
den neuen koch offen sofija betreibt in
kumasi ein friseursalon sie führt uns
den ofen vor gerade kocht sie ein
reisgericht dann zeigt sie uns ihre
küche zu unserer überraschung steht da
ein moderner gasherd der weit weniger
co2 ausstößt als jeder kohleofen
das ist mir zu teuer geworden deshalb
nehme ich meistens den kohleofen
und wenn gas wieder billiger wird
welchen nehmen sie dann
der ist einfach günstiger auch tatjana
du viel gleich nebenan freut sich über
die neue günstige alternative zum gas
ich habe gerade nicht das geld und nicht
die unterstützung deshalb lasse ich den
gasofen stehen
auch sie hat ihren gasherd durch einen
holzkohle rufen ersetzt das gegenteil
von klimaschutz
wenn die neuen öfen nicht effizienter
holz kohle verbrennen sondern in
wahrheit nur die sehr viel besseren
griffen verdrängen dann ist das kein
klimaschutz das würde das problem der
co2 emissionen sogar verschlimmern
egal wen wir fragen überall bekommen wir
die gleiche antwort gas wird für kohle
ausrangiert
wenn es noch teurer wäre würde ich gas
nehmen ein gasherd funktioniert schon
aber ich habe ihn ausrangiert
das ist mir zu teuer geworden
geworden ich benutze den gasherd nur
noch um damit morgens für meine kinder
schnell frisch zu machen
wir fahren zur universität von kumasi
wenn kohle gas ersetzt kann die rechnung
mit den co2 einsparungen durch die all
die öfen nicht aufgehen professor
michael com erklärt wie gerechnet wird
vorerst komplett
wie sie gesehen haben ist die formel
relativ komplex aber
alles was sie eigentlich sagt ist wie
viele emissionen der neue und im
vergleich zum alten ofen tatsächlich
eingespart
doch
wo bleiben dabei die vielen gasöfen die
formel basiert im wesentlichen darauf
dass traditionelle öfen verdrängt werden
das deckt sich nicht mit unserer
stichprobe wieder konfrontieren wir alle
dieses projekt vermittler climatepartner
mit unserer recherchen antwort
der vergleich und die effizienz
ermittlung zwischen zwei
unterschiedlichen koch werden wird hier
ausdrücklich nicht angestrengt
[Musik]
es gibt zahlreiche wege die berechnungen
so manipulieren und in der theorie die
emissionen zu reduzieren
aber wenn man genauer hinsieht entpuppt
sich das schnell als weitgehend illusion
wenn wir das klima schützen wollen dann
kommt es jetzt darauf an die emissionen
hier vor ort in deutschland deutlich zu
reduzieren
wenn wir jetzt stattdessen auf
scheinlösungen vertrauen wie fragwürdige
projekte im globalen süden wo überhaupt
nicht sichergestellt ist dass die
tatsächlich das klima schützen dann
hilft uns das überhaupt nicht weiter und
wir brauchen uns an der stelle nicht in
die tasche lügen die jüngsten meldungen
zu erderwärmung sind schonungslos offen
der weltklimarat warnt der co2 ausstoß
muss runter so schnell wie möglich vage
versprechen von klimaneutraler milch
helfen da wenig